we have video of a father and daughter
being interviewed by Fox News after
being reportedly cleared of coronavirus
quarantine by health authorities and the
video is not particularly comforting
because throughout the video the guy
being interviewed can't stop coughing
and is visibly sweating including
coughing directly onto his daughter as
he fares a bottle of water with her
before insisting that the cough is
caused by being nervous from being on
television now I want to be clear I'm
not saying this guy has the virus that
would be not based in evidence even
though there have been people who tested
negative multiple times and then later
tested positive but the guy clearly has
something and he can't stop coughing but
in the midst of all the precautions
everybody's supposed to be taking when
you see someone visibly sweating and
coughing and sick on television in a
segment about being cleared of
quarantine it's not the best visual take
a look at the video I think as time goes
forward hopefully doctors and scientists
were gonna better and a handle on the
whole situation fortunately from what I
understand you know it is contagious but
the death rate is is pretty low so yeah
I understand the fear yeah well we can
see you still have a coughing what did
the doctors say about your own condition
and moving forward as we wrap this up
they said yeah I'm fine I got tested
twice negative both times the cough
probably just that fair enough he coughs
he takes his daughters water drinks out
of it hands it back to her she drinks
out of it and I'm sure this is a super
nice guy lovely father but if this is
what we're dealing with in trying not to
spread disease we've got to be very
worried because this guy's doing
everything you shouldn't do when you're
sick be out of your house in a TV studio
with tons of other people share bottled
water with other people cough on to
other
people it's almost like an SNL skit in
the visual component how are we going to
deal with this if this is what is being
considered reasonable safe behavior at
this point coffin to the or elbow not
into your daughter's face and he's
saying in the clip this is contagious
and then takes a swig of his daughter's
water after coughing on to her and then
hands the water back to her I don't even
know the point of the segment by the way
apparently the idea is hey this is just
somebody with a bad cold Fox News wants
to do that maybe to run interference for
Trump but the guy is out in public in
contact with the makeup person the
camera person the greeter at the studio
and on and on and on so I don't know if
the point of this clip was some kind of
thinly veiled Pro Trump propaganda to
show hey here's a guy he's fine
he doesn't have kovat 19 so Trump is
right that a 2% death rate instead of
0.1% death rate isn't that bad like what
is even the point of this segment and I
first heard about this when Tim Poole
tweeted about this segment and started
looking around for the video and I
thought it can't be this bad and it is
the guy is unable to stop coughing
directly on to his daughter and reminder
the kovat 19 test isn't that reliable
there have been a lot of false negatives
and false negatives are a real problem
in this particular case here leading to
a guy at a studio uncontrollably
coughing including onto his daughter
while talking about how fortunately he's
fine
is anybody else concerned by this to me
I get it it's that there's a good chance
he doesn't have COBIT 19 but when I saw
this it did not inspire confidence we'll
have the clip as well on our Instagram
page at david pakman show make sure
you're following us there and follow me
on Instagram at David Pakman I've got a
picture up I had a big meeting of the
minds brunch yesterday with Stephen
Kenneth destiny Bunnell the second and
put up a picture on my Instagram at
David Pakman check it out quick break
much more coming up right after this
short break